[Music]
kudos to the producers in bathroom
paradises just cast Corinne Olympia's
for their new season we were first to
break the news last night on ET online
and now we're gonna show you why Corinne
is perfect for Paradise you go go you do
you i'ma do me for months the sassy
blonde breakout star from Knicks season
of The Bachelor plated coy when we asked
her if she's headed south of the border
in search of wall I don't know what I
would do if I was asked fast runner in
paradise is always a question still
there was no question that the 25 year
old was practically made for the reality
show set Mexico with you I see you we
know Corinne's not afraid to turn up the
heat I want to get even more romantic
with Nick so expect things to get a
little spicy with or without props
remember that trench coat stump bachelor
in paradise is known for pushing the
envelope there are night-vision cameras
24-hour cocktails and everyone seems to
have only packed swimsuits which we know
is OK with Corinne ah love's bikinis and
bubble Omega but with all that Sun and
champagne here's hoping the NAP
enthusiast doesn't pass out and get
burned oh my god sorry guys I got but
there is someone sure to keep Corinne on
her toes we're hearing her bachelor
nemesis Taylor Nolan may also be in
paradise it's ridiculous so expect to
see a whole lot of drama if they square
off for round two this August
now the stink face on your face you're
just not nice the eloquence the teenage
just concern the classy moments like
that that we miss well guess what you're
not gonna have to because we just found
out Corinne will be on The Bachelorette
next week things you can get a little
bit dirty because no thank you good luck
little stinky some might said because
grunting sets up a mud-wrestling
competition between the guys all right
that's gonna be interesting
[Music]
you